this country is in spite of our recent
chaos
is on balance pretty likely to go to the
fbi
compared to to most institutions and
groups
some people don't give in to the dollar
sign they
are booked by ideology athlete julie
harvey
oswald he was a very very pointed
and enthusiastic killer and he
was to assassinate kennedy and return
back to moscow and have them be cheering
and enthusiasm for him at the moscow
airport
how did stalin's leaders that were left
after he died in the mid 50s
how did they feel about kennedy kershaw
he wanted
kennedy dead but he realized that
he might get caught and labeled as the
assassin
of the american president and that could
mean nuclear war between
the us and the soviet union interesting
he changed and the decision was made
by oswald not to listen
and not to obey anybody and he
basically executed him
[Music]
my guest today is the former 16th
director of cia mr james
woolsey and we have a lot of interesting
topics and experiences that he's had
that we're going to get into today with
that being said
james thank you so much for being a
guest on valuetainment thank you great
to be with you
so it's it's uh you know any time i've
had i remember one time i had a
cia agent we were running a uh executive
meeting with a company called vistage
and i was the host i had to bring
somebody in as a guest
and it was a former ci agent he came in
every single ceo and entrepreneur showed
up because they just wanted to hear
the different stories and uh it was
by far the most popular guest we had
where ceos wanted to hear from a ci
agent go figure why
a ceo but it's exciting to share your
story with our audience so
you know if we can go back on how you
got started how does
one go from you know graduating from
high school to saying i want to go be a
cia agent and
not only that you get a phone call from
bill clinton saying hey i want to meet
with you and that leads to you being the
director of cia
so how did this whole thing get started
for you well uh it was close to being an
accident
um what uh happened was uh
that i was a conservative democrat
um still kind of angry and uh
i think the administration as uh the uh
uh as the administration came into
its position with the new administration
uh they wanted uh to have
probably all parts of the system of the
political system represented
and they didn't have any conservative
democrats and so they
named me but they hadn't done their
research all that thoroughly
and they announced me as admiral uh
woolsey and um i said you know i
never was an admiral uh uh never got a
book captain in the army
and uh they had a crowd gathered by that
point
uh to hear the announcement and they
one of the staffers said whoops we
better change the press release
uh so i was a last-minute uh uh
conservative democrat uh and uh that's
why
i think they uh searched for me and
and found me it was not a real
polished operation very very interesting
by the way who would you say uh because
you know you don't hear that term too
often today who would you say is a
current conservative democrat
and would you put jfk as a conservative
democrat
i would have at the time yes uh the last
one i i think probably was joe lieberman
he's often often named as that
but joe is retired as a matter of fact
the last time i call myself a
joe lieberman democrat joe was in the
group with me he said jim you've got to
stop
saying that i'm not in politics anymore
i said you know
joe if i can't be a conservative
democrat and call myself a lieberman
uh democrat i'll i'll go back to harry
harry truman was a good president
why not use him so but any case
conservative democrat it is conservative
democrat
conservative democrat do do we do we
have a lot of current conservative
democrats would you say
maybe two not so much
uh i think the democrats
have yawed over into being progressives
largely and uh the republicans uh
have gotten very much into
i think some of the innovations of
how to how to create a new movement for
themselves
and i'm not sure uh there are many
conservative democrats i think they're
kind of gone with the win you said two
of them is mansion one of them
is that who you're thinking is one of
them i would say mansion and i still
count to lieberman
okay got it okay very i mean you know if
you think about it a lot of people would
probably be
uh america probably would be comfortable
with
uh someone more on the center left or
center
right than being far left or far right
uh you know it would balance out the
eagle's wings
if somebody was more on the center left
or right rather than going far to the
right
or left i think you're right yeah so so
how was that phone call made when you
got the call and saying hey the
president wants to meet with you
and were you expecting it i know you
said it was kind of a surprise but was
it something where you were on a short
list of five names that you knew about
not really
um i was on a short list
of people that they were talking to but
i thought they were just talking to a
group of people who were being
considered
to be director not uh who had
already been chosen as an admiral
to uh to be directed
it was uh it turned out i was on the
shorter list than i knew
how was your first sit down with uh
president clinton
well we uh we really didn't uh
sit down uh uh it uh it
happened very quickly uh uh president
clinton
uh uh chatted with me
uh at the inauguration uh
ceremony for a few seconds uh that's
about it
yeah i heard you tell a joke one time
you said
you know in the two years of me being
the director of cia you know the plane
that
tried to fly into the pentagon or white
house that was actually me trying to get
a meeting with the president because
he wouldn't sit down with you well
that's basically true uh bill clinton
was
was is a speed reader and uh so he
didn't want to sit down every morning
and hand the director of central
intelligence read
sheets of paper to him uh he can he
could read a lot faster himself
and so he would just
let the system operate in his speed
reader so
occasionally you wouldn't know what he
was reading but
i remember one time he said jim have you
read that new book uh
on africa by uh so-and-so
um what did you think of it and i i
happily had read it
uh but uh he was reading a lot of books
as president and uh uh talking to people
about him
but uh it wasn't very formal and he
didn't he didn't want there to
be any nod toward
toward having a system
of reviewing is that is that a protocol
like typically
the president's first meetings to get a
briefing by the director of cia every
morning is that typically historically
what it's been what's been the case or
no
it's happened and it has been the case
several times i think but it's it's
there's nothing
required about the president
designates the director as director and
the director
uh gets briefed on this
kind of panoply of the briefs and then
start
or started the meeting with the
president the next
day and but that's that changed
uh in part with me yeah that's what i
wonder i mean if you're a president you
would want to meet with the director of
cia
to kind of see what's going on if it's
not once a day maybe once a week to just
kind of be briefed
uh especially when you say in two years
you never got a chance to meet with them
uh were you reporting that kind of like
you know how you run a company and
sometimes you put your org chart
together and you say look
i'm the ceo i have the cfo the ceo the
cio the cto whatever and i got five
direct reports typically the ceo doesn't
want to have more than five reports
sometimes it's seven but let's just say
five's the magical number
were you reporting to the chief of staff
did he want you to go through another
layer before you go through him who were
you directly reporting to
functionally yes chief of staff
uh and he uh he liked it the president
would report to him and that was
kind of the way it worked out it wasn't
absolutely a rule
and when we would go in together
uh tony and i to uh
say something uh to the president i
was it was okay with them as we walked
out if i stopped by the president's desk
and said
mr president you want to pay particular
attention to x and y
the report today it was that sort of
thing was fine
got it so day before you became the
director of cia versus the day after the
day you became a director cia
what were some of your responsibilities
how dramatically did your
responsibilities change the day after
becoming the c
director of cia well i think the
main change uh is the change
from being just a reporter of
intelligence to being
in a situation where you can recommend
and sometimes get approved
covert actions covert action uh
is an event that's put together in order
to try to
influence what the policy is rather than
just report on it
and it's not there's nothing sneaky
about it from the point of view of the
president not knowing about it the
president's
fully briefed and he gets a signed uh
recommendation
for from the director and
uh it all is proper and done
but it um is it it's an action item
and that sometimes those are
successful and sometimes they're not and
bill clinton was very
uh disturbed he said one time in a
close meeting that
he had not gone into rwanda
uh and uh stopped the uh hutus
uh killing of the other rwandan
tribes um it was uh really uh
the tootsies uh were massacred
essentially
during the rwanda killing fields of
eight to 93 94.
and um that uh
what i think president clinton didn't
want to have is that he did not want
another uh event like
the black hawk down where american
troops got killed
uh on the ground in somalia and
and so he was being very cautious and he
did not
stop the uh rwandan hutus from killing
the tutsis
and he was very as he thought about it
over time
he decided that had been a big mistake
and he would often tell people and this
is one thing i
i rather admire about clinton he would
tell people
okay you need to know the biggest
mistake i made
as president it was going not going in
and protecting the the tootsies i should
never
have let them massacre the hutus um and
most all presidents don't do things like
that they they don't say
write out in the national security
council meeting you know i made a big
mistake and here's what it was
because that was close to a million
people that died um
as a result of that decision of his and
it's
um um something that uh
has come up in time a number of
circumstances
uh but uh it's um an important issue and
and it's something that he had the the
manhood and grace to uh
to deal with uh straightforwardly was
was that during your time when a million
people died during his watch was it when
you were his director of ci
was it afterwards uh it was largely
uh during
about 94 and i was director in 93 to 95.
got it do you think it could have been
prevented if he was communicating with
you more often and getting updates or it
wouldn't have made a difference
i don't think uh the
decision about going in to
protect the tootsies or not would have
changed
based on who was director he just didn't
want to do that
so uh so it wouldn't have made a
difference whether
you would have given him the briefing or
not because he was determined not to
make the move and but he admitted to the
fact that
that decision was a decision he made
that cost a million people's life so he
took responsibility for it which is what
great leaders do
so you know prior to being a director of
cia
how much experience did you have being a
cia agent yourself
when i went on active duty in the army
uh to
um pull out
fulfill my requirements as a
infantry officer uh in the
reserve officers training corps
requirements
uh i had a choice whether to work on
intelligence
issues or work on issues related to the
vietnam war
since i had been a founder and president
of yale's citizens for eugene mccarthy
for president and had opposed
the vietnam war i i picked intelligence
rather than the vietnam war
and uh i uh worked on intelligence
matters
largely um having to do with satellite
design reconnaissance and i did that for
close to two years
and then after that i began doing some
national security council work for uh
brent scowcroft
and uh worked
in the pentagon uh so um
it was in the technical side of things
uh and was
relatively short a couple of years uh
but uh uh i uh that's
that's what my experience was yeah i
mean i look at your
resume advisor during a military us
delegation for strategic arms
limitation talks in vienna 1969 to 1970
general counsel to u.s senate committee
on armed services 1773 under secretary
of the navy 77-99 delegate
at large of the u.s soviet strategic arm
reduction talks
and nuclear and space arms talks geneva
1983-86 ambassador to the negotiation on
conventional armed forces in europe
vienna 89 to 91 so it's interesting that
you had a variety of
background on different things today
does that kind of give you an edge on
why they thought about recruiting you to
be the director of cia
it's possible uh that
reasonably broad experience uh although
not
uh deep and not real lengthy i mean it
was
screened over a two three year set of
assignments
when you became a director of cia were
you given some intel
where you yourself were you thought
the outcome
or the blame was somebody and then you
found that it was somebody else where
you sat there and said
this is pretty interesting on the intel
that was given on what event took place
here was there anything that you
yourself were
extra curious about that as a director
of cia now you can have access to find
out more about that information
yes uh drones i uh
was a uh enthusiast uh for
uh making a transition for at least an
important portion uh of the photo
reconnaissance
uh uh part of the agency and the
pentagon uh that would have been backed
up the idea
of relying more heavily on on drones
as a matter of fact in the early mid
80s um before i
uh became the general counsel of the
senate armed services
committee uh i i was a
private citizen doing one thing in
another and i got asked to come over to
israel
to work with the idf
and i did things like that
from time to time and because
i was over there i saw something that i
was
really impressed by which was a um
essentially a group of very young
israeli troops uh
flying drones uh which i hadn't seen
before in the american military flying
drones
and uh they seemed like they were
just almost certainly too young to be
doing things with military forces
and so i asked the colonel who was in
charge of the israeli
unit i said colonel this is
really an interesting operation you've
got these
young troops flying drones and they're
shooting down
[Music]
tank ordinance
from uh uh uh above
above them uh there's just a lot here
going on um what are
what's going on why do you have just to
be very young
uh troops doing something like this it
looks like it's
hard to do and and important and and and
difficult and the colonel grant and he
said well
he said they ought to be fairly young he
said this is the
uh israeli team
that essentially does uh
operations uh in training and
uh the reason they're they're young is
that this is the israeli
model airplane club and we just put them
into uniform
and uh uh called them up and they're
doing a great job
i i remember thinking that's that that's
smart
that's uh you got a whole new way of
using ordnance and different new
ordinance
so you go to the 14 year olds and sure
enough they're doing a great job
very interesting you know i recently
interviewed
the former director of a mossad shabtai
shavit i don't know if you are familiar
with shabtai shavit
i just went to a conference there where
he was speaking and i introduced him
he was a good friend for the two years
we were both heads of our services
i bet and the question i have for you is
when i asked him a question i said look
everybody is trained by somebody right
like i'm from iran so
the savak was trained by mi6 and secret
service and a little bit of
you know the mossad you know you think
about uh
you know mi6 was trained by us
cia and cia was also trained a little
bit by mi6 and kind of share each other
what they know maybe not all the secrets
the question i asked them who trained
mossad to be as good as they
are you know so i'm curious you know who
you would say train the mossad to be as
creative and as uh you know some would
say brutal as they are
well i think it's more uh
cross-referenced
uh really than that uh i i i think
the cia and including the nsa which does
some very useful and important uh work
that are code breakers
um i think that they
and uh the uh
mi6 brits uh and uh
cia work with one another
very readily and very easily
[Music]
and uh they also work very closely with
uh
called the i-5 uh the
commonwealth uh uh intelligence
uh troops uh the australians and the new
zealanders and the
brits and so forth um so
um it's more a group of
six or eight that work together on all
sorts of things all the time
than it is a single sequence
why would why would the secret
intelligence groups teach
each other their tactics of what they do
basically it's because we have no
major secrets anyway from the the brits
and the canadians and the aussies
uh we uh we're all in the same same
ballpark
who's one you wouldn't be comfortable
sharing secrets with if you were to say
there's no way in the world we would do
anything with the following three who
who would it be that would be
iran iran iran
[Laughter]
so iran's at the top so you're more
uncomfortable with teaching iran
anything than china i think china's
doing a clinic right now around the
world with people no china is doing a
lot and they are
they worry me and the russians worry me
i'd say i'd say realistically
russia china uh uh iran um
are uh syria
any of the countries that are uh clearly
uh at odds uh
uh with us but that's four or five uh
there
are a few that would work with us even
though
not all the time interesting so before
we get into your new book that's coming
out operation dragon inside the kremlin
secret war on america
uh i want to kind of ask you maybe a
couple other questions here regarding
today's times you know
i've asked this question from multiple
different people
to see what their answer would be uh
being a director of cia 93 to 95
had different issues than we're facing
today then maybe in the 70s then maybe
in the 60s it's different challenges
during different decades
what what what concerns you the most
today
i mean i'm talking is it cyber warfare
is it bionuclear is it nuclear is it
you know bio warfare is it uh
a uh oil war that could take place
is it you know what what is the top
concern that you have with all the
different challenges we're facing today
well it's tough because it's a
combination
on the one hand of intelligence
forces or groups i mean i'm much more
worried about
iran than i am about most any other
country
and and but in addition to
naming some names like iran
um i'm i'm
really quite
concerned about
especially specialities that have been
adopted by russia and china
which are are very very troubling
because
russia for example has been working very
hard
on cyber particularly artificial
intelligence
and that that is
continuing source of uh
confusion and uh difficulty for the
united states because uh
uh the russians
lie cheat and steal about who they are
and
that makes it very difficult
what do you do with somebody with a face
mask
that's extremely well designed and
you're sure that uh he's uh uh a syrian
in fact he may not be
he may be opposed to syrians i don't
so there are um um
a lot of difficulties
with masking and such uh technology
uh cyber poor in all dimensions
uh are is really hard to deal with
uh and um i'd say uh
that uh set of of technologies and that
set of um
governments uh are uh
are six eight ten twelve
uh really really troubling uh
combinations of
of uh individual countries
and individual uh texts and
and uh operators
so when when you were director of cia
from 93 to 95
uh obviously russia was probably your
biggest threat would you agree russia
would be number one on the list 93 to 95
as a nation
i think probably so uh we
we were not as uh worried about russia
then as i think we
should have been and uh we
uh uh worked to some extent
uh on uh the uh
steps uh russia could could take uh
in masking themselves
and they did that a lot
uh they uh the temp potemkin
village uh history uh the
disguise for a whole village uh by
count potemkin who is sort of catherine
great's uh
male friend uh was uh
one of the things the the russians did
and it did
going back to the 17th century um they
they're good at deception and we we
were always needing to penetrate that
was not easy during that time
was china at all even a thought uh you
know was it even something where you
woke up and
you know hey we have to be careful what
china is going to be doing next
obviously russia was up there iran was
up there was china still in the top
three at the time or no
i don't know that it was in the top
three
but it was very close it was it was in
the top one or two
or three uh you can't you can't really
tell but uh they were a problem but not
as serious the problem i think we
thought as
russia was now it may be different the
ranking of the chinese and russians and
iranians
syrians is
hard to parse but uh all four or five of
those
countries are worrisome so you know the
one thing that sometimes i wonder about
threats
is when you were the director cia at the
time you know the story of uh
aldrich ames who was arrested february
21st you know in 1994
for treason spying against the united
states et cetera was criticized for not
taking action immediately and you came
out and said
i'm not the kind that's going to go out
there and fire the guy let's investigate
a little more before
some find out who disguise if it's
really involved and then later on that
year
december 20th 1994 you you resigned so
the question i have for you with this
is how you know you've heard the saying
before alexander the great i have met
the enemy it is i
or america's biggest enemy is within the
inside in a family
the thing that could break up a great
family is within the inside
how much do we have to worry about
another aldrich ames or 2 or 3
or 10 you know sharing some of our intel
with our enemies
today we have to worry about
the inside um it's
a serious problem
uh most uh cia and uh dia and
other uh intelligence uh people uh or
other other people on the inside
military officers and the like
lee harvey oswald after all was a marine
uh uh sniper
so because of uh uh
that scope we do uh have to uh
uh uh be very careful
with our people including very senior
people who
work on really important matters but
um it's not
something that we can readily brush
aside and it's also something that you
want to be careful not to get too
fired up about it or you you know even
paranoids have
real enemies but you don't want to
spread a doctrine throughout the
intelligence community that you're
suspicious of everybody uh you ought to
be
it's interesting we're concerned and
attentive about everybody
but uh we need our career people
and we needed them badly yeah i bet
that's kind of weird to s you know how
do you
[Music]
how do you watch your agents and how do
you
you know have detectives to detect
any signs of espionage from your cia
agents who are professionals
at kind of keeping things under cover
and people not knowing what they do for
a living it's a tough task
i said to one of my successors and he
didn't think it was a good analogy but i
said it anyway
in a meeting that we
lived with a national security
establishment in which we
um send people
abroad military usually
to fight and die for their country
we also sometimes send uh
people from my organization abroad
to lie cheat and steal for the country
and i had one of my colleagues say we
don't steal
i said well you know what what do you
call it if you
get your hands on an enemy draft
security set of files
you don't uh just kind of smile and
leave them there you
uh uh give them to the boss find some
way to
use them uh and uh
the the best thing that's ever been said
on that i think
is the wonderful winston churchill
quote which is that
it is uh so important
to take very good care
of intelligence that
it's a
essentially like
a dominant dominant
pattern of of of work
what do you mean so churchill said it's
important to carry your intelligence
because they could they could do it
because they could get
the exact quote it's uh it's about uh
oh i know what it is it's that it's uh
so important it's uh
intelligence is so important and must be
protected by a bodyguard of lies
when intelligence is so important that
it must be protected by the bodyguard of
lies
and that's winston churchill wow and
and uh he one of his books is called
bodyguard of lies um and uh it's an
important
point uh churchill uh uh was very good
on these issues to put him mildly
yeah he's uh he's a obviously in in many
ways he's seen as one of the greatest
leaders of all time and he's
hated and he's uh um you know
a lot of misconception about him and
people who didn't really understand his
wiring because he was a pretty weird
strong personality leader when you know
wartime came they trusted him the most
to want to execute and some of the other
guys like chamberlain were not having
the guts to go out there and uh
do what the necessary work was required
but
going back to it so espionage
cia agents flipping on us or dia or
whoever it is that we're even some
soldiers there right
what is the common uh oh tipping point
where somebody says i'm willing to flip
is it a is it women where you know
they end up meeting some you know the
stuff they see in movies a red sparrow
or something like that and
all of a sudden like oh shoot i totally
screwed up i gave too much intel to the
wrong person because this woman
really was able to woo me and i'm in too
deep is it
money because you know ci agents don't
make a lot of money if you think about
the kind of money ci agents make it's
not like they're taking home a million
dollars and
you know rolling in the dough with a
porsche 911 park that said that only
happens in movies
is it a deep hate for the institution
and what america stands for what what
typically gets somebody want to flip
against its own nation
well uh lots of uh people
can show weakness and different types of
people
have and do uh ames uh uh
uh came into his uh
desire for a great new car
and a lot more money than he had some
people don't um
give in to to uh
the dollar sign they uh they uh are uh
uh hooked by by
ideology on uh on the other side
and uh that that happened again i'll use
an example that heart happened to lee
harvey
oswald he uh was a
very very pointed and enthusiastic
killer
and he was uh
what he really wanted more than anything
else was to
assassinate kennedy and return uh back
to moscow
and have there be cheering and and
enthusiasm for him at the
moscow airport he said that on several
occasions so
um people operate for
strange mixtures of reasons sometimes
but it's not always uh uh
the happy pleasures of uh
of friendship or it's not always the
the angry pleasures of getting an
added salary in your pocket it's uh
it's different things to different
people it makes sense i mean
it's it's similar temptations but you
wonder how you're able to get somebody
to
stay loyal to an to a country and an
institution when they're not making the
money to not be tempted to do something
otherwise
um okay so so you know why don't we go
and talk about your book uh
and the jfk assassination and uh
you know what your thoughts were on who
was behind it based on access to
research and folks you worked on with
the book so
when you when you and i go out there and
read about
jfk assassination there's a lot of
different theories that come out and
you've read all the theories probably
way more than any of us because
you wrote a book about this and you've
had to do research on it so
whether it's the you know the bullet was
it him was it
uh you know the mob was it the mafia
was it uh johnson lyndon johnson was it
a couple people that were missing
politically later on maybe they were
involved was it
who was it so based on your research and
theories that you have
what really happened with the jfk
assassination well uh
first of all we call the book operation
dragon uh
and uh dragon in the russian terminology
a lot of the time means
very effective deception uh that's what
they
sometimes call their their deception
operations
and that um uh creates
uh a a
reason for them to
move into both
uh trying to self-aggrandize
and trying to help
the new country or institution or group
of people that they have decided to
unfortunately to help so there's two
batches
of people who
get involved in working for the other
side in
intelligence and counterintelligence
against them
is uh what we in the intelligence
business spend a lot of time and effort
uh trying to force stall so
what conclusion did you come up with
when you wrote this book
with uh former romanian spy chief yan
uh mihai pasepa what conclusion did you
come up with
uh on who assassinated president kennedy
it seemed reasonably clear to mike the
chapa
uh we all called him mike by the way
because that
his romanian name with eon mihai is
mike and
we uh uh i i think it's
fair to say that uh
mike uh was a
romanian patriot and did not
uh and and worked hard to help
us uh during the post-war
years the post-civil post
cold war years and during the cold war
he worked hard to help us
corral and limit and penetrate and
understand uh
the enemy and uh
he and he was at the thick of the fray
at one point he
was being chased uh i don't know if his
wife was in that particular
chase but she he was in a chase
with carlos the jackal who had been
tasked
to kill him um and so uh
this was a a ge engineer
[Music]
whose father was a general electric
engineer he worked in
in the establishment of
infrastructure of the system
uh but uh he had a flair and an ability
for
um counterintelligence that was uh
very very effective and uh we ended up
uh being able uh to
uh use his skills uh
effectively and uh he
was a remarkable individual
he passed away by the way a week almost
exactly a week ago
he passed away exactly a week ago
wow um so
so you know when you're sitting there
and investigating this
you know there's a lot of people again a
lot of different claims have been made
on who killed jfk
why why specifically like
maybe i ought to ask the question a
different way what is your level of
certainty
on what you believe in with the events
that took place with the assassination
of john f kennedy
um quite hard and i have a
major reason for its being quite high
and that's that i had mike
and mihai pachepa um for years
spending uh time and effort uh cozying
up
uh to the russian
uh cabinet essentially uh
uh chatting briefly with khrushchev
during uh
vodka breaks etc uh
the uh the whole
world of essentially
intelligence was open to pachepa
in ways that it was not open really to
virtually anybody else
and um so that's one one thing
uh mike uh um was
able to get into contacts and
for example chesca the romanian
intelligence intelligence chief
and and and actually and and
chief of decision making for much of the
time
in romania pachepa um
was a uh just a great
gate into into that world
and uh i think that
we were very lucky to have him and his
very able wife as
sources uh and and uh they
they they served us extremely well
got it so so the claim you guys make you
and the co-author is lee
lee harvey was a kgb associate who was
personally instructed by
soviet leader nikita khrushchev to
assassinate president kennedy sometime
shortly after
the soviet changed their minds and
oswald was told to drop the plan but
oswald
harboring a blinding love for all the
ussr refused so that's that's the claim
that's the pretty much the premise of
the book but
what what how did stalin view uh
kennedy what was stalin's relationship
and view of kennedy
oh he hated him with a passion because
kennedy
had uh basically made him look foolish
uh in the uh cuban missile crisis
and and weak uh turning his own ships
around
so they wouldn't confront the americans
uh he uh khrushchev
was furious at kennedy and he wanted him
dead
and he wanted to have him killed is that
stalin or is that khrushchev
who wanted him dead that was crucial uh
stalin died in what 53
um this this is all
post-stolen but not by much
early i guess the question i would have
is
stalin's camp you know the secret speech
that khrushchev gave the four hours
where he trashed stalin and stalin is
this and stalin is that as stalin as
this
stalin's people were still in power
obviously they were not
running it was crescent but it was
stalin's people i'm trying to find out
how did stalin's
leaders that were left after he died in
the mid 50s how did they feel about
kennedy
well uh the book goes into that in some
terrible mikes in my book they
they uh also uh uh
wanted kennedy dead and were extremely
hostile to him
and then what happened really was
that that khrushchev finally
got a little bit of balance and sense
into his
thick skull um he
was essentially ready
he by the 60
early 60s um to move
against oswald whom he knew about and
and so forth to do something
to to create a situation
where the the the
kennedy would be killed um and
uh it was only really
because of his hatred kennedy
that he was willing to take that step
and then when he did take that step
and ordered it happened it was not
necessarily face to face with
uh oswald but but it was substantively
easily known by the bureaucracy
the party bureaucracy that he he had
given the order
he had so given the order in with such
clarity
that oswald learned that he was being
tasked with this great marvelous
wonderful job that he so wanted
more than anything in the world and he
essentially gets approval to move
against kennedy and
the um and what really
happened was that oswald was picked
and moved against kennedy and then
khrushchev got a little bit of sense
into his thick skull
and he wanted very much more than
anybody ever has wanted a president did
he wanted
kennedy dead but he
realized that he might get caught and
labeled
as the assassin of the american
president and that could mean
war between the us and the soviet union
nuclear war he decided he didn't want
nuclear war
so with with a sense a real sense of
unhappiness
he changed and pulled in and pulled back
and um krushaw basically dictated that
and that was where things were
heading when the decision was made
by uh by oswald
not to listen and not to
obey anybody
oswald turned around
essentially after having been part of
the group that was
ordered to kill kennedy mike believes
that i believe
i believe that was clearly a
decision by oswald to continue on
and kill kennedy under a a
vague overall charge from krishna
you know it's it's uh uh i've spoken to
folks who have interviewed about this
topic one is jim jenkins who was one of
the folks in the room who held
jfk's brain after he was assassinated
and he saw
cuts incisions and he saw bullet wounds
from the back
so for him you know he has no
there's no way he believes anything that
happened from the front you know where
from the where everyone claims it was
oswald
lots of people think it was cia because
it was an inside job because lbj hated
kennedy
and you know he just wanted him gone
because lbj always was more aspirational
wanting to be a president
than than kennedy was and he couldn't
stand a family he would always say i
want those
irish men out of there and you know i
want to go in there and
be the president and he was aspirational
to want to be president
lbj and we all know what happened when
john f kennedy went up to him saying i
want you to be my vp it was not the
easiest conversation
so but i i i don't think
lbj was aspirational enough to do what
kershaw did
uh the uh the key uh
thing here is if one did
look at the brain of kennedy's brain
one saw something that only
the autopsy people who worked with the
treasury
department medical folks
uh saw which uh was
that the
there's whole books on the autopsy by
the way
but the thing that you want to pay
attention to is the treasury
department study that was
done in order to
look at the brain
of kennedy once he had been shot
and to see whether or not the way the
blood flow
and the soft tissue flowed was
consistent
with one type of approach toward uh
being killed by a rifle
versus another type and the treasury
department study of this
is new enough now that it hasn't been
relied upon particularly by
the autopsy the anti-autopsy people and
the other people the other
members of the 3000 people who
wrote books about about kennedy the
killing
of kennedy was consistent
with soft tissue being at the front end
of the brain and consistent with
the type of entry wound whereas
i'll let you read all this in the
treasury book because it's it's the one
that has the detail in it
but but the the other
sort of texts of um
information essentially came from
killing with a shot that ended up going
through
the much harder surface of the brain
rather than the soft
under the skull tissue and um
i think uh it's clear from what mike has
has told uh
us and what uh i think it's
clear from the from what
chapter saw and and passed on
that the death of kennedy
was consistent and highly consistent
with a bullet coming from where the
bullet
finally was was said to uh
enter uh kennedy's uh skull
so if if lehigh lee harvey oswald did it
why would ruby kill him afterwards like
what what connection does ruby have to
russia i mean what does ruby have to do
because ruby's connection was to the mob
yeah ruby's connection was to the mob
and the mob
uh ordered him uh through cuba uh
because they had the driving
responsibility uh for this uh uh
they had standing in line they had
people who were willing to kill kennedy
they were ready to go and uh they were
ready and willing to to take a
action against kennedy
and that required them to take uh
action against uh lee harvey oswald
uh because if oswald and oswald was
still alive at that point remember
that's after one day
uh and uh oswald is uh
at the uh in jail and uh
and a famous photo of ruby shooting him
in the stomach
um but what uh what happened was that
uh uh oswald uh
gets uh uh killed
uh by uh ruby in the jail
as uh they pass by uh one another
and uh ruby is killed because
neither the mafia nor the
castro want him nor the russians
want him alive talking to anybody do you
have
is this speculation or do you have proof
of this communication
i think it's pretty clear i'll let uh
i i'm i have stayed away in the book and
i will stay away from
words words like
absolutely clear and and and so forth
but i think both motivation and the uh
geography of where people were uh point
very clearly toward uh ruby
uh killing uh oswald and having
done so uh because the russians and the
uh
and the uh cubans uh didn't want uh
uh him or anybody uh
to know what he was what he was doing
um you know are you a sports fan are you
someone who likes sports
i've i have gone both ways
uh when the redskins were were here i
went to almost every game um
other sports i
i tend toward baseball but
that's gone on evil days as a result of
the virus
so as soon as baseball comes back in a
sensible way i'll be
out there in the stadium soon so you you
know how a kid
is raised in a family in boston and he
grows up hating the yankees right
and he's five years old sitting next to
his daddy and he's just watching the oh
my gosh that's a d
you know what these yankees are con
artists
and a kid grows up 30 years later these
yankees are con artisan and his kid and
you know generationally
they hate the yankees and it stays with
them from a kid till later on
even 70 years old they still hate the
yankees magic till today when he hears
about the celtics
his body shivers because he can't stand
the celtics because it was his number
one enemy right and you go on and on and
on and on and on
how much of you you know
knowing when you were coming up you know
enemy the state number one was
russia fast forward today how much of it
has to do with
you just despise russia where you think
they would be capable of taking out
kennedy because you had aspirations of
kennedy
because you're a conservative democrat
and how much is it just
logically you said you know what i just
want to write a book about this because
i'm certain lee harvey oswald was behind
the assassination of kennedy
none of the above um i uh
went into the world of national security
through
uh interest and was developed when i was
uh
working on the reconnaissance satellite
uh stuff for the pentagon
uh that was two
two two and a half years of basically
technical
research and understanding how the
satellites
work and so on um i
i didn't feel an emotional uh
requirement
to do anything with the russians i as a
matter of fact
um when i negotiated the conventional
forces in europe
treaty back in
the late 80s
um i got along reasonably well
with the russians they were
uh uh
not my favorites but uh i could get
along with them and uh
and and did what was the fabric of doing
business with russians like what did you
know they stood for dot dot dot
here's what it was doing business with
russians the thing that i found to be
their saving grace
in a sense was that they had a good
sense of
a lot of times they had good senses of
humor i often look at people's senses of
humor to
make temporary judgments and
um so on the whole
had pretty good senses of humor my
german friends in the negotiations
uh didn't so much
but my uh my russian acquaintances
um i uh i could get along with
um and uh in all of those cases
the the best humor was certainly british
i mean the brits just do
that well um so um
but i uh but i i did
uh get along with the russians
okay and uh i i
neither sports nor that was really
central to my uh
decision making i i would do my best
to have decisions
come through in a way that
let me
have a lighthearted demeanor in dealing
with the
27 countries that i had to deal with and
uh i always tried to
pay people compliments and so forth to
keep things on an even keel so who told
who told
dirtier jokes british or the germans
actually british or the russians this is
a diplomatic uh
core uh they were not not
not good with dirty jokes although i
think probably the
the best ones uh would probably have
been russian
i can see that somehow i can say so were
you a big reagan fan with him telling
his sense of humor
constantly telling jokes from stage well
i didn't
really know reagan i i i
worked he was one of the four presidents
i worked for uh
and i enjoyed my one or two meetings
with him but i
i didn't know his personality or his
personal style i was a the
head of a negotiating team i was uh
not a close confidant of the president
last question for you before we wrap up
if
you were the enemy today okay
say russia comes to you with a blank
check they said james
um we're going to give you a billion
dollars
china is going to give you a billion
dollars iran's going to give you a
billion dollars
tell us what is the best way to attack
america today
what would you say it is excuse me i'll
talk to you tomorrow and then i'll go
right
and say i'm going in to see a russian
who's
pitched me uh tomorrow um
uh how do you want me to handle it i'll
uh either
play a game with them or i'll just say
go to hell
but uh if you want me to uh
lead them astray let me know i respect
that
i respect that you know the the but but
did you do you
and you don't even have to answer this
i'm just curious uh
asking you this question
would you know the best way to
internally
destroy america and if yes
is it in the progress of that becoming a
reality and we have to fight like hell
to keep it or
no the strategy you have no one's
talking about it
i think that uh the thing that would
probably uh
influence not me but uh but a
potential person like who like ames
decided to go
with the russians because of money i
think the thing
that would most influence somebody
like that uh would be
his effort
probably to please his
wife and family and children and better
just stack up money i mean if he can
without people knowing about it if he
could
stack up tens of millions of dollars
enough to lead a very
wealthy life that would be the kind of
person i think that would be most likely
to uh to turn to the russians so
the ideological folks who
want to have a
[Music]
lee harvey oswald type life and
climb onto the ladder of the arriving
aircraft coming back to moscow and
getting
cheers and
everybody loving them that that set of
motivations um
i think can be pretty hard for folks to
come to now
if only because it's hard to
find people who are
going to make decisions based on
something like that because they're
afraid to get caught
but i don't think there are that many
americans that would go
[Music]
the route of of uh uh
leaning on the the the russians
for the future there might be a few
that would lean on uh a
russian ideology as well
has happened over history with a range
of uh
of people that
took mainly
payment in in affection and
and uh uh
and desire like uh uh like oswald
so uh i don't know um
i i think it might be more likely to uh
find a chinese who was willing to do
that because i think their numbers are
so huge
that the possibility they would
come across someone who was willing to
take either funds or
uh uh ideology in a sense
uh as their payment uh it could be a
pretty substantial number of people i
don't know if the chinese would because
the chinese even if they pay you
and you turned against them the
government would take out your family's
life they would the fear of taking out
your life americans if you turn against
the country
the government's not coming out of your
family because the government would
still
keep your family intact china they
if you cross the country the country's
above the individual
and america at least gives you a little
bit protection of the individual that
even if you cross the line so that's why
i think
it'd be easier to turn against america
than it would be to turn against china
again i'm just a business guy i'm just
speculating but
uh uh you know i'm not the one that's
the director of cia here i'm the one
that's interviewing the director of cia
so
i uh okay you uh this country
is in spite of our recent chaos is
uh uh i think on balance
uh pretty likely to go to the fbi
um compared to to most uh
i agree institutions and groups i i i
totally you know i asked the question
from you
only because when i sit there and i
strategize with my board
or my executives and i ask you know the
question comes up about
if we were our own enemy and number one
competitor
how would we try to hurt us
you have to think about that you have to
ask that question because you learned
that way
i asked that question because i would
hope you know and i would assume this is
happening
the folks in charge of the cia the
whatever
organizations that are out there that
are trying to protect the country
they ask the question if the enemy
wanted to take out america how would you
go about doing it
you know what would that strategy be
because that would be what i would be
spending my time having
almost like a blanket insurance policy
around it to make sure that never
happened
and how i go about doing that would be
you know the
right execution i'll tell you one
because i got clearance from the
cia because i was writing an op-ed um
some months ago i got clearance from
them to
write this up and have it published so
i've got to say i think it would be
pretty effective which is to put um
into a
early old division uh
electromagnetic pulse warhead
a emp
warhead that could be detonated
at a low level that could be detonated
um with um
a
device that uh was a simple one
like pretty much like the the nuclear
device that
was exploded that we used to hiroshima
and nagasaki
first time that was brought up was by
newt gingrich by the way in the 2011 or
2012 debate when he brought up the emp
and
i was like what the hell is an emp it
had been around for a while but
no one when they ask what's the biggest
threat everybody gave the general answer
and then newt ginker shocked the whole
world then everybody started googling
emp yeah yeah no that's right that's
right
uh he and i've been on panels together
and stuff right about this but the
bottom line is just detonate a
low yield nuclear uh device
and you want to do it
up at least let's say a mile
or two you could probably still have an
effect if you detonated it
up several miles and it would um
take out pretty much uh all of the
electromagnetic devices including the
the um
the uh
you know what am i thinking of uh the
phone towers the servers the internet
the electricity yeah all of those
uh but also the electric grid if
you may have mentioned it that takes
everything
uh within limits uh and so
being able to detonate an emp
is potentially devastating
uh hopefully everyone's gonna play nice
you know hopefully everyone's gonna play
nice and hopefully everyone's
rather than thinking about attacking
each other they're playing a nice game
of solitary or backgammon or
spades or dominoes or whatever their
choice and preferences of playing a game
but knowing when you're competing in the
game of power
unfortunately they're spending more time
thinking about tactics and strategies
of protecting themselves against the war
then worried about who's going to get
the highest score
on backgammon or solitary so maybe what
we have to do is instead of sending that
emp
we send the biggest distraction of video
games
you know movies shows to distract the
hell out of these leaders so they're
consuming more entertainment than
you know going out there thinking about
attacking each other who knows
maybe i watch too much cartoons with my
kids and my mind is going into cartoon
strategies than actually real life
strategies
you realize that uh uh we're being
saved from the evil cartoons um
by uh um just as of yesterday
uh they're taking uh the um uh
bugs bunny i saw that uh taking
um uh half a dozen of the
key characters because we're doing the
evil thing by watching them
with our kids sometimes you know the old
dr seuss and
pierce morgan yesterday got cancelled
as a conservative democrat what do you
think about the cancel culture
absolutely idiotic really so you don't
you don't agree
with the fact that we
cancel what people say that could
potentially hurt someone else's feelings
that that's right my response to that
when i hear it is almost
always get a life i appreciate
that yeah
it's uh it's definitely one of the
scariest thing that's happening because
it's the ultimate muzzle you know i left
iran
living in a country with a big muscle
where you can't even think negative
thoughts about the country and then you
come to america
that handcuff shackles and muzzles back
on just in a different way and you can
only listen to one way of thinking not
the other way so
who knows what's going to happen uh look
i got to tell you i enjoyed it
i uh uh got smarter
i learned more uh of whether if i ever
get the call to
want to be the director of cia to turn
it down indefinitely
and you know stick to what i'm doing for
living
and for everybody that's watching this
uh uh
james we're gonna put the link to your
book below that folks can go order
specifically those of you that are very
very curious about the jfk assassination
highly recommend you go get the book
and read it for yourself and if you
agree or disagree
tell us about it but with that being
said once again sir thank you so much
for making the time for being a guest on
valuetainment
many thanks appreciate it very much
great interview appreciate you thank you
so many different versions of the jfk
assassination story what was your
biggest takeaway and as well as what it
meant to be a director of ci
any of the strategies when he and i
talked about as a conservative democrat
how he viewed
different topics i just want to hear
your thoughts and if you enjoyed this
interview i think
i think i think you'll enjoy a short
clip of a
interview i did with jim jenkins who was
in the autopsy room one of only four
people who held
john f kennedy's brain and this is what
he saw
in the autopsy room watch this short
clip something tells me after you watch
this short clip
you're going to want to watch the entire
interview thank you everybody bye